[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en marte porque la nasa reveló
el vídeo y el audio del momento en que
el explorador perseverance a martiza o
se posa sobre la superficie marciana se
trata de la primera secuencia de vídeo
de un robot llegando al suelo de otro
planeta y muestra lo difícil del
descenso pues en siete minutos desde que
atravesó la atmósfera de marte hasta que
aterrizó se tuvo que reducir la
velocidad de 20.000 kilómetros por hora
a cero
[Aplausos]
esto es martín estamos en el lugar que
vamos a explorar durante los próximos
meses y años y es muy emocionante verlo
estas escenas lucen familiares para
nosotros tienen una similitud con la
tierra las ven las montañas allá y las
rocas y otras cosas solo que realmente
la superficie de un mundo exterior
borrow esta ha sido considerada la mayor
y la más ambiciosa misión de la nasa a
marte hasta el momento el percibirse
aterrizó sobre el cráter yesero que
según creen los expertos hace tres mil
500 millones de años era un lago de 45
kilómetros de diámetro alimentado por un
río para esa época marte era un planeta
azul como la tierra por lo que se piensa
que hubo condiciones básicas para que
surgiese algún tipo de vida pues
justamente ese es el objetivo del rover
buscar signos de vida pasada
hay dos micrófonos en el perseverante
contamos con estos dos instrumentos para
grabar sonidos absolutamente increíbles
de la superficie de marte así que con
ello los invitamos a cerrar los ojos y a
imaginar que están sentados en la
superficie de marte y escucha
los alrededores
cambiamos de tema y hablamos de ccoo y
19 el descubrimiento de nuevas variantes
ha puesto la eficacia de las vacunas en
el centro del debate público en las
últimas semanas mientras los países
implementan sus programas de inoculación
los científicos ya están trabajando en
la siguiente generación de vacunas con
la esperanza de que la denominada vacuna
universal pueda ser la respuesta que
todo el mundo está buscando pero será
esto posible veamos el informe este
laboratorio en la ciudad francesa de
lyon está buscando la fórmula que podría
ayudar a acabar con la pandemia de kobe
19 aquí estamos trabajando en una vacuna
universal contra las distintas variantes
de corona disc creen que han encontrado
la correcta ahora sólo están buscando la
dosis adecuada la compañía
biotecnológica ha estado trabajando en
una vacuna universal contra la gripe
desde 2013 y ahora están poniendo en
práctica todo lo que han aprendido en la
lucha contra el coronavirus la mayoría
de los proyectos se centran en la cadena
de proteínas de coronavirus pero a
medida que esa cadena
cambian tú tienes que cambiar la vacuna
lo que estamos haciendo tiene como
objetivo lo que está en el interior del
virus lo que significa que aunque el
exterior también la vacuna necesaria no
lo hace si todo va bien los ensayos
clínicos podrían empezar a finales de
2021 a medida que aparecen nuevas
variantes los científicos de todo el
mundo están a la caza de la fórmula
capaz de combatir todas las mutaciones
pero la vacuna universal es siquiera una
posibilidad los investigadores no están
seguros si creo que el término vacuna
universal es una estrategia de marketing
lo que probablemente llegará al mercado
no será una vacuna universal sino una
vacuna que te protege contra distintas
variantes lo que ya es mejor que las
dosis que hay en el mercado ahora pero
no algo que yo llamaría vacuna universal
de baksán de herschel a medida que
avanzan las investigaciones de nuevas
vacunas los científicos están de acuerdo
en una cosa la gente debe confiar y
aplicarse de las que ya están
disponibles
finalizamos con los robots de reparto de
mercancía de la empresa colombiana aquí
we bought que operan principalmente en
eeuu
actualmente unos 50 de estos robots
funcionan en ese país
su intención es prestar un servicio que
llegue a millones de personas las
personas en colombia en 2017 como un
experimento de amigos haciendo delivery
para estudiantes dentro de una
universidad
el modelo fue muy exitoso vendimos la
empresa y eso nos llevó a participar en
el programa nacional de shark tank
recibimos unos fondos que nos trajeron a
la aceleradora you see ver clic aquí en
california posterior construimos la
dinámica del robot
hemos creado 275 robots a lo largo de
cinco iteraciones diferentes la pandemia
ha sido un espacio clave para que las
operaciones de kiwi bots
se incrementen al aumentar los pedidos a
domicilio con los robots las entregas
son más seguras pues no hay contacto con
humanos asimismo los responsables de la
compañía aseguran que cada vez son más
los negocios que quieren hacer más
eficiente
de producción sin importar la clase o el
estatus social hay un número 300 de
personas con problemas respiratorios
problemas de salud que ya tienen una
barrera adicional entre lo que necesitan
en lo que tienen y nosotros hemos
trabajado con ciudades con filantropías
para poder atacar este problema y poder
reducir esa brecha adicionalmente muchos
negocios se encuentran la necesidad de
generar sistemas más eficientes para
toda su cadena de producción
concluimos así este espacio recuerden
que pueden repetir este y otros
programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]